yeah well I should disclose the court
book is a very good friend of mine and
I'd say yes I actually think Cory's one
of the most inspirational people that
I've ever met not just when he speaks he
absolutely and fervently believes in
doing something and doing the right
thing to change the way our our urban
centers you know are viewed and taking
on Newark has been just an extraordinary
task and a really difficult difficult
one for him but he is a very special
voice and he's an incredible speaker he
has got one of the best memories of
anybody I've ever heard he can go on for
an hour and a half and pulling quotes
out of the air from everything from the
Talmud to you know Martin Luther King
and just endlessly sort of winding the
story to a wonderful conclusion and I
think he does represent something new
and different he is certainly not wedged
into the mainstream of New Jersey
politics and he's you know a little
threatening to certain people because of
that but I think he's got an incredibly
bright future and there are some other
young politicians in New Jersey that
sort of seemed to be following suit on
the Republican side actually rather than
on the Democratic side but I do think so
I think that Corey's youth and ability
to inspire people very much parallels
Barack Obama's ability I don't know when
he and I met at the Democratic National
Convention back in o4 and he had just
come out of doing a speech and all these
people were around him and they were all
excited and is when we're saying that
was the best speech I've ever heard you
should be President of the United States
and then this woman turned to him and
said yes mr. Obama can we have your
autograph
and he said well there's more than one
sexy black man in America so and he's
you know just rolling rolling with it he
really is sort of absolutely committed
to doing what he's doing without an eye
to what's next which is unusual in
American politics anywhere I mean almost
at every level the second somebody runs
for school board they're thinking about
running for council or freeholder and he
really wants to do this and I don't
think he'll leave Newark until he turns
it around I hope that's true